hola bienvenidos en este vídeo ya quiero
dejar la moneda justa por el bien y
pensar en algo más entretenido así que
vamos a pensar en el basketball en el
baloncesto y vamos a suponer que tengo
un porcentaje de tiros libres es decir
mi porcentaje aciertos en los tiros
libres es del 80% es decir de cada diez
tiros libres que hago en sexto 8 y fallo
2 otro como decir esto es que mi
probabilidad de encestar un tiro libre y
probabilidad de encestar 1
es de 0.8 es la probabilidad de encestar
una canasta en un tiro libre ok y
entonces qué pasa si me preguntan bueno
cuál es tu probabilidad de encestar 3 de
5 tiros 3 de 5 tiros y bien vamos a ver
un par de ejemplos sencillitos qué es lo
que podría pasar por ejemplo un caso
podría ser que yo encesta el primero en
cesta el segundo en cesta el tercero
pero luego falle el cuarto y falle el
quinto otra forma en la que podría
obtener tres canastas de cinco tiros
sería decir que encestó el primero pero
falló el segundo pero encestó el tercero
pero falló el cuarto y encestó el quinto
estos son dos ejemplos de un modo en el
que podría obtener tres canastas de
cinco tiros y cuál es la probabilidad de
cada uno de ellos
pues antes de calcular esa probabilidad
recuerden que los tiros de basketball
son eventos independientes es decir que
falle o no el primer tiro no tiene
ninguna influencia sobre el segundo tiro
y el que falló el segundo tiro o el
primero no tiene ninguna influencia
sobre el tercer tiro así que por las
reglas que ya hemos visto como son
eventos independientes la probabilidad
de obtener exactamente esta sucesión de
eventos es simplemente el producto de
las probabilidades de irlos obteniendo
uno por uno la probabilidad es estar el
primero es de 0.8 por la probabilidad de
estar en segundo que de 9 es de 0.8 por
la probabilidad de encestar el tercero
que también es 0.8 por la probabilidad
de fallar el cuarto si la probabilidad
de encestar es de 0.8 entonces la
probabilidad de fallar es de 0.2 un modo
en el que podrían pensar en esto es si
mi porcentaje de tiros libres es del 80%
eso significa que el 20 por ciento de
las veces
de ahí saliste 0.2 y finalmente esto por
0.2 que es la probabilidad de fallar el
quinto tiro así que todo esto cuánto es
pues lo podría recomendar o más bien
simplemente escribir compactamente y
decir que es 0.8 al cubo por 0.2 al
cuadrado y fíjense tres más dos es 5 ok
y en este caso qué pasa pues tengo 0.8
para insertar el primero por 0.2 para
fallar el segundo por 0.8 para insertar
el tercer tiro por 0.2 para fallar el
cuarto por 0.8 para encestar el quinto
y reacomodo de nuevo obtengo 0.8 al cubo
por 0.2 al cuadrado y siempre que tengo
un evento en el 15 este 3 canastas quien
se este tres tiros y falle dos de ellos
siempre la probabilidad va a ser 0.8 al
cubo por 0.2 al cuadrado cada canasta
contribuye con un factor de 0.8 y cada
fallo contribuye con un factor de 0.2
así que esencialmente lo que tengo que
hacer es averiguar cuántos modos
distintos tengo de encestar tres
canastas y fallar dos tiros si pienso en
mis cinco tiros como los números del 1
al 5 1 2 3 4 5 lo que estoy haciendo es
diciendo cuáles de estos tiros voy a voy
a encestar por ejemplo podría insertar
este este y este y fallar estos dos así
que esencialmente lo que estoy haciendo
obteniendo las formas de elegir
entre cinco elementos quiero elegir tres
y esas formas me las da precisamente el
número de combinaciones o el coeficiente
binomial de 5 en 3 que recuerden es 5
factorial entre 3 factorial por 5 - 3
factorial o sea 2 factorial
y esto simplemente es 5 por 4 por 3 por
2 por 1
/
por dos por uno por dos por uno
ahora esto cancela esto
este uno lo puede ignorar este dos
convierte este 4 en un 2 y esto me daría
10 así que tengo 10 formas de encestar 3
canastas de 5 tiros y cada una de esas
formas tiene una probabilidad de 0.8 al
cubo por 0.2 al cuadrado entonces mi
probabilidad
mi probabilidad de encestar tres
canastas de cinco tiros
0.8 al cubo
por 0.2 al cuadrado que sería un solo
evento por los 10 eventos o los 10 modos
que tengo de encestar tres canastas así
que cuando es esto aquí ya tengo mi
calculadora y entonces tengo que 0.8 al
cubo por 0.2 al cuadrado
por 10
punto 2048
así que 0.20 48 o si lo quiere escribir
en un porcentaje esto es aproximadamente
el 20.5 por ciento de los casos en los
que voy a acertar tres canastas de cinco
tiros vamos a hacernos otra pregunta que
quizás sea más útil en el basketball
cuál es la probabilidad de encestar al
menos al menos
tres canastas
en cinco tiros pues si esto al menos
tres canastas o encestó exactamente tres
canastas tres en cinco o en sexto
exactamente cuatro canastas en cinco
tiros
y encestó cinco canastas en cinco tiros
y cada uno de estos eventos es
mutuamente excluyentes y entre este tres
no pude haber encestado cuatro o cinco
así que bien este número este primer
número la probabilidad de encestar tres
canastas en cinco tiros lo acabamos de
calcular fue 0.20 48 vámonos ahora con
este otro la probabilidad de encestar
cuatro canastas en cinco tiros pues como
se ve un evento típico parece estar
cuatro canastas en cinco tiros podría
ser algo como esto la primera falló la
segunda y encestó el resto o podría ser
algo como encestó las dos primeras falló
la tercera y encestó las dos últimas
pero en cualquiera de estos casos cuál
es la probabilidad la probabilidad de
estar un tiro es de 0.8 y aquí tengo
1234 4 canastas así que voy a tener 0.8
multiplicado 4 veces o lo que es lo
mismo 0.8 la cuarta
por cada fallo me proporciona un factor
de 0.2 y en este caso sólo tengo un
fallo así que tengo este factor de 0.2
de hecho podría aquí poner un sumo y
noten que 4 +1 de nuevo me da el número
de tiros que es 5 y lo mismo para este
caso entonces igual que lo hicimos antes
esta probabilidad va a ser igual a 0.8 a
la cuarta por 0.2 que sería un evento
típico de esta forma por el número de
formas en las que puedo obtener este
evento que sería de nuevo esencialmente
elegir cuatro lugares de cinco
disponibles para hacer las canastas así
que ahora por las combinaciones de cinco
en cuatro y cuántos son las
combinaciones de cinco en cuatro pues
déjenme lo noto por acá arriba las
combinaciones de cinco en cuatro son por
definición cinco factorial entre cuatro
factorial por cinco menos cuatro que es
1 factorial
y esto cuánto es pues esto ustedes
pueden checar que 5 así que cuánto vale
este número déjenme saco mi calculadora
pues ahora es 0.8 a la cuarta por 0.2
por 5 y eso es
punto 40 96 así que esta probabilidad
vale 0.40 96 o si lo quiere escribir
como un porcentaje esto es
aproximadamente el 41 por ciento de los
casos ok y por último cuál es la
probabilidad de encestar cinco canastas
en cinco tiros pues en este caso sólo
hay un modo de hacerlo encestar las
cinco canastas así que la probabilidad
de esto es de 0.8 a la quinta potencia
de nuevo saco mi calculadora y 0.8 a la
quinta potencia es igual a 0.32 76 así
que esto es igual a 0.32 76 o escrito
como un porcentaje esto es lo mismo que
32.8 por ciento de los casos ahora bien
lo que yo quería era la probabilidad de
al menos 3 en 5 así que tengo que sumar
esta probabilidad que está aquí arriba
con esta con esta y eso cuanto sería
igual
déjenme vuelvo a sacar mi calculadora
esta probabilidad sería la suma de 0.20
46 que sería la probabilidad de 3 en 5
esta de aquí más 0.40 96
0.40
96 que sería la probabilidad de 4 en 5 +
0 puntos 0.32 76 que sería la
probabilidad de los cinco tiros
encestados y eso me da punto 94 18 así
que la suma medio 0.94 18
esa es la probabilidad de obtener al
menos tres canastas en cinco tiros
escrito como un porcentaje esto es
aproximadamente el 90 y 4.2 por ciento
de los casos lo cual es bastante
bastante alto y esa es la respuesta a la
pregunta cuál es la probabilidad de
encestar al menos tres canastas en cinco
tiros libres es de 0.94 18 o del 90 y
4.2 por ciento